good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight sinaloa is a province in
northwest mexico it's directly across
from the bottom of baja california it's
not that far from the united states and
that's a bad thing because sinaloa
mexico may now be the single largest
producer and distributor
of the synthetic opioid fentanyl
cartels are making fentanyl in mass
quantities in sinaloa now but they're
not making it for domestic consumption
within mexico they're making it to
export here
and you can see why
in the capital of sinaloa 11 pounds of
fentanyl typically sells for around 15
in the united states that same amount of
fentanyl sells for more than a hundred
thousand dollars
so you can see the incentive how much
fentanyl is that well just two
milligrams of the drug can be lethal to
a human being that means 11 pounds
contains nearly two and a half million
fatal doses of fentanyl
again there's a major financial
incentive for the drug cartels which run
huge parts of mexico to produce this
drug and ship it north and they are
if cocaine was the drug of the 1980s we
are now living in the fentanyl era and
the numbers show it
not so long ago between october 2012 and
october 2013 customs and border
protection seized just two pounds of
fentanyl total at our southern border
compare that to what we're seeing now in
the first eight months of this year
first eight months the us government
seized more than 7
200 pounds of fentanyl it's the highest
amount seized by far and keep in mind
that's likely just a small percentage of
the fentanyl that came over the border
since it is odorless and difficult to
detect
according to a recent report by the u.s
sentencing commission quote since fiscal
year 2015 the number of fentanyl
offenders reported the commission more
than doubled each fiscal year resulting
in a 3
increase
meanwhile federal authorities recently
announced that they have seized nearly
10 million counterfeit pills and many of
them were laced with fentanyl that was
all in a single year
news reports from chicago say as they do
in so many cities fentanyl has become an
epidemic
the pill on the left is xanax the one on
the right is counterfeit not knowing the
difference can be deadly the drug
enforcement administration warns of a
dramatic increase in fake prescription
pills flooding the market from criminal
drug networks in mexico the drugs made
to look like oxy or adderall are laced
with fentanyl or meth often in deadly
doses the dea has seized more than 9.5
million counterfeit pills so far this
year and the head of the chicago
division says they've seized more than
600 pounds of fentanyl
so why are we telling you all this about
fentanyl because the rise in the
consumption of fentanyl mirrors the rise
in the availability of fentanyl which is
causing the massive rise in deaths by
fentanyl od
and all of that
is a result of the bidet
administration's immigration policy when
you open the borders it's not just
people who comes in
it's massive amounts of fentanyl and
other illegal drugs so the bite
administration tells you that their
border policy is quote humane
but it's just the opposite that policy
has resulted in this country becoming
flooded with fentanyl and it's resulted
in the deaths of many thousands many
thousands of americans the latest data
from the cdc shows that drug overdose
deaths in the united states hit a new
high almost a hundred thousand deaths of
american citizens during the 12-month
period that ended in march of this year
how much more is that from last year
what's a 30 percent increase in one year
so
there are a lot of reasons this is
happening
but one of the main reasons is
government policy which has made the
population sedentary and depressed our
government spent the last year in case
you haven't noticed locking everyone
inside their homes
and the result of that
is that drugs are everywhere and major
american cities are now unrecognizable
take a look at this report from san
francisco's local news station watch
the rate of accidental drug overdoses
hospitalizations and deaths is outpacing
the city's expanding teams of crisis
intervention specialists fentanyl a
powerful and highly addictive synthetic
opioid much cheaper than heroin entered
the san francisco drug market a few
years ago fentanyl has been the large
driver for these increases in accidental
overdose deaths
the powerful narcotic was responsible
for more than 500 deaths last year and
has become the drug of choice for many
users in san francisco ktvu has been
documenting the epidemic for months many
experts believe that social isolation
from the coronavirus may be contributing
to the death toll
so what we refer to habitually as our
homeless crisis which is bigger than
it's ever been in american history is
not primarily about homes it's not even
primarily about mental illness strictly
speaking it's mostly about drugs and
drug addiction
none of this should really surprise us
our leaders have spent the last year
dividing americans from each other the
result is loneliness they close the
churches they close the gyms they force
people to stay apart from their family
friends and the people they're closest
to
and at the very same moment the bite
administration has opened the borders
allowing a massive wave of this highly
addictive deadly synthetic opioid to
enter this country so what do you think
happened well an awful lot of people
died
and this was a result of bad policy
but the byte administration
isn't simply ignoring the problem
they're not apologizing for it of course
they're doing something even more
destructive they're making it worse
they're making it less possible
for the us government to control what
comes across our border you remember
they blamed the border patrol for daring
to patrol the border on horseback now
they've dominated a genuine radical an
extremist called chris magnus to lead
customs and border protection how
extreme is chris magnus
well during his confirmation hearings in
the congress yesterday magnus was asked
repeatedly whether what is happening at
the border is a crisis and repeatedly he
refused to say that it was
tens of thousands of americans are dying
because of this border policy and yeah
here's the man
who the by demonstration would like to
run the border
responded watch
you believe we have a crisis at the
southern border yes or no
senator i
i'm not sure does it really matter
whether we call it a major challenge a
crisis a a big problem do we have a
crisis at the border yes or no
senator let me assure you that no one
believes there is greater urgency
to this matter than i do you're saying
there's not a crisis at the border
senator i know i don't think they're
i don't think i don't
speak too urgent as less serious at all
in fact is there a crisis or is there
not a crisis at the border give me that
senator i would say
that my highest priority is going i
didn't ask your priority i asked to
characterize the situation on the border
is there a crisis at the border what i'm
certainly trying to convey is how
serious i take what's happening at the
border and the amount of work that i
want to put into addressing it
so here's a guy who's totally beholden
to the radical non-profits the ngos many
funded by george soros that control our
immigration policy he's so beholden to
them that he can't tell an obvious truth
under oath for fear of offending them
they're his real constituency not you or
anyone else who lives in this country
it's the radical ngos that would like to
open the border knowing full well
that doing so will result in the deaths
of many thousands of americans from the
drugs that are also coming across the
border but our leadership class is so
decadent that they don't even
acknowledge that drug use is a problem
or a crisis as chris magnus refused to
say
they think it's fine
so chris magnus says he's going to take
the border very soon as you well know
that he is going to do his level best to
allow as many foreign nationals to come
here as possible and many will be
bringing drugs
so this is more than just irresponsible
it's more than just ideological it is
reckless it is dangerous it is criminal
the role of the federal government is
not to protect economic migrants from
haiti it is not to improve the living
standards in other countries it is not
to pack the electorate on behalf of a
specific political party it has only one
role
and one role alone
it is to protect american citizens is to
serve their interests
but they're not doing that they're doing
exactly the opposite hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else